Our friend called us
and said that the war had begun.
When Russia attacked Ukraine on 24 February 2022,
the European Parliament and the EU
immediately condemned the aggression.
Europe took action to support Ukraine.
We understood that staying in Kyiv was very dangerous.
As Russia's aggression grew bolder
and the destruction increased,
Parliament backed round after round
of economic sanctions on Putin and his enablers.
We drove for 27 hours without stopping,
we didn't sleep, we didn't eat, nothing.
When millions of people fled the rockets and shells,
Europeans opened their doors
and the EU granted refugees unprecedented protection.
Of course, we are extremely grateful to European countries
that came together at the start of the war
and took in a huge number of Ukrainian refugees.
Poland helps a lot with clothes, food and medicines.
They don't just bring help,
they always ask what people need.
As Russia plunged Ukraine into darkness
by attacking power supplies and civilian infrastructure,
as winter began to bite,
Parliament sent Generators of Hope.
I am worried about my relatives who stayed in Ukraine.
They live in fear of renewed attacks.
There are so many problems with power and food supplies.
When Russia committed war crimes,
Parliament declared it a state sponsor of terrorism.
When Ukraine’s economy buckled,
Parliament backed suspending import duties
and voted for €18 billion of support for Ukraine in 2023.
As Ukrainians fought for their freedom and democracy,
Parliament called for more weapons
and assistance for the country's military.
When Russia tried to isolate Ukraine,
Parliament backed granting it EU-candidate status,
paving the way to join the European Union.
Ukraine's future is in the European Union. Slava Ukraini!
I believe that Ukraine is a European country
and our mindset is not very different.
Slava Ukraini!
Glory to the heroes!
We were with you then,
we are with you now,
we will be with you for as long as it takes.